[Music]
hey you guys welcome back to tomes of
terror this is my book review series so
here's another book that i just randomly
picked in my kindle unlimited
recommendations just because i thought
the cover looked interesting and the
title sounded kind of intriguing so this
is a book by an author named daniel j
volpe i think i'm pronouncing that
correctly if i'm not i apologize now i
had actually heard his name before
somewhere i can't really remember where
but i didn't really know much about him
like as a writer and had never read any
of his prior works so i kind of looked a
little bit into his background and it
seems that he's mostly known for doing
kind of like extreme horror or splatter
punk type stuff
and i will say that um while the novel
that i'm talking about today which is
called left to you and it came out in
2021 it actually is very gory and like
very stomach churning in places i don't
think i would necessarily categorize it
as extreme horror so there's that
and i will say too that it's actually a
really
heart-wrenching story which is kind of
centered around a real life historical
horror
as well as a kind of really
savage examination of what some people
will do in order to
save their own skins or save people that
they love now as with most books that i
discuss on this series i'm going to
recommend going into left to you knowing
as little as possible about it because
that's what i did and i really liked uh
not knowing anything about it like not
knowing what direction it was gonna go i
had no idea what the story was about
literally i didn't even read the
synopsis on this one i just like was
like oh that looks like a cool
cover and it's like that title sounds
kind of interesting done so i like
checked it out and started reading it uh
because i'm going to be talking about
certain plot points i'm not going to
spoil the end or anything like that but
i am going to be talking about certain
plot points that you might not want uh
revealed prior to reading it so there
will be kind of mild spoilers from this
point forward as i said if you have
kindle unlimited you can go in there and
read it for free and i actually would
recommend it because i liked it very
much so the novel is actually divided
into several sections
now the first of these follows kind of
like a young he's i think he's like 21
22 something man he's just out of
college or whatever and his name is
robert and he lives with his mom in
upstate new york
now robert is portrayed as just like a
really really decent dude right um he's
working hard at kind of two thankless
jobs he stock shelves at a you know like
an lmart you know like a walmart or
kmart type situation and he also waits
tables at like a greasy spoon type diner
and he's trying to kind of support his
household
his mom is slowly dying of cancer and
it's really kind of like tearing him up
inside to see like this formerly vibrant
woman who is just wasting away and in
constant pain
so there is he does have like a home
health aide named esther who comes in
because robert has to work so much to
you know kind of keep the lights on and
everything like that but you know the
bills are still piling up you know he
doesn't you know his mom got cancer he
couldn't really finish college and blah
blah so it's like he's just working all
that he can work so you know bills are
piling up and robert knows that after
his mother inevitably passes away which
seems like it's going to be soon he's
not going to be able to afford to keep
the house so he's kind of in a little
bit of a pickle
so aside from that though i mean his
life like most other people's lives is
kind of just full of petty little joys
and annoyances and things like that um
his biggest problem other than his mom
dying is you know he has this manager at
elmart who's kind of like named mike
who's kind of a pain in the ass um but
then he also has this friend at work a
potential love interest maybe uh she's
uh named sarah she also works at elmart
and she actually has a big crush on him
but he's kind of been keeping her at
arm's length he's like look i really
don't need that on top of everything
else right now but he's like you know
maybe later on down the line because he
does really like her so you know it's
just they're little things like that
that are going on
most significantly though robert has
this sort of casual friendship with this
very kind older gentleman named joseph
now he actually just kind of met him at
random the old guy was like shopping in
his in the lmart one day and he kind of
like helped him out like getting him
some stuff from the back and uh you know
the guy lives in the neighborhood so he
sees him in the store all the time and
so he just kind of started talking to
him so like i said they just struck up
kind of like i don't even know if they'd
call it a friendship but they're just
kind of acquaintances and they always
kind of like talk and hang out they seem
to like really like each other um also
joseph well sometimes he's actually like
a polish immigrant and so the uh greasy
spoon the diner where um where robert
works also like the cook there
does like a really good like polish
stuffed cabbage and like joseph will
come in sometimes and have that so it's
like then they can talk so like i said
it's just kind of this little friendship
and the guys clearly um you know i think
it's implied that he's like in his 70s
or 80s so he's quite elderly but lately
though joseph the older guy has been
feeling uh particularly dire he's really
having some uh
if you're real sensitive about reading
about um like diarrhea and stuff yeah
you might know what you might want to
skip some of these pages it's pretty
gross um but i mean it's reality but
it's still pretty gross um now although
robert doesn't know this uh joseph's
body is also being ravaged by cancer and
joseph is very very aware that his
remaining time on earth is growing short
so he's starting to get sicker
and he starts getting like increasingly
desperate to
stay alive for just a little bit longer
because he has to tell robert something
really really important and you know so
he has to like hang around long enough
to do that
now to this end uh there's a really
upsetting scene like that happens right
here where joseph
you kind of know
where it's going because he's like just
a few more days i have to stay alive a
few more days so i can tell him this
important thing and then in the next
scene joseph is going to the humane
society
and adopts like of like an older uh i
think it's a golden retriever like a
really nice dog named molly very
trusting very sweet and you know the
lady at the humane society is just like
oh it's so nice that you're adopting
like an older dog we can't usually you
know usually the puppies uh go quicker
and everything like that and you just
know something bad is gonna happen to
this this poor poor girl
and uh indeed it does so you guys know
how i feel about uh bad [ __ ] happening
to animals and stories like this and
this one even though a lot of it is
quote unquote off screen i think like
even just like the lead up to it this
like legitimately like made me like
almost want to cry so it's just kind of
like just know that going in that there
is a scene like that in there so it was
very very upsetting so the next day
joseph who is looking and feeling a bit
better
he actually contacts robert and says hey
can you come over to my house for a chat
now joseph somehow already knows that
robert won't have to work that day he is
like scheduled
but um apparently what happens as it
turns out there's like some kind of
plumbing problem or electrical problem
or something like that like at the diner
and so they can't open because they have
to have the guy come uh you know fix it
so he's like yeah you know i had a shift
today but some bad [ __ ] happened they
can't open the diner so you know yeah i
got time to kill so i'll come over and
hang out with you
so he shows up at joseph's house joseph
pours them both some bourbon
uh telling robert yeah we're both gonna
need this by the end of the night and
then he starts to tell robert a story so
the next section of the book actually
takes place in 1943.
joseph uh his wife ola and their twin
sons have actually been rounded up by
the nazis in poland and are being being
transferred to auschwitz
uh the family is of course as soon as
they get off the train they are
separated and joseph actually never sees
his wife or children again and doesn't
find out until much later like what
happened to them
so he's basically put on a work detail
um and his job uh entails like removing
the dead bodies from the gas chambers
and then basically like hosing the
chambers out for the next set of victims
so obviously he and his fellow inmates
are starving and terrified and you know
this is just like the [ __ ] worst [ __ ]
ever
but they soon learn to kind of buckle
down and work without complaint um
because they see like some of the other
prisoners obviously just getting lined
up against the wall and shot
you know and the nazis just like
shooting them for just the smallest
infraction not too long into joseph's
confinement though
the director of the camp whose name is
lieutenant colmer
he learns that joseph is a professor of
theology
and he summons him to his office for a
talk about religious topics
now joseph obviously is initially very
wary of this especially after culmer
pretty much tells him point blank um
yeah once you're you know once you bore
me or once you're no longer of use to me
or you're no longer interesting then i'm
gonna kill you like i don't like you or
anything like that so he does tell him
that like right from the jump but over
the next few months like he keeps
calling uh joseph out like on his lunch
period he just goes in there and like
sits with him for all this time and
after a while like joseph almost starts
to like enjoy his lunchtime chats with
this evil [ __ ] like the camp
commander
uh colmer actually starts doling out
little favors you know like he allows
him to have fresh cold water to drink
instead of you know the warm polluted
water that they're giving to the other
inmates and after a time uh culmer even
starts having kind of like really nice
rich like lavish meals like lunches
brought for both of them to eat while
they're just while they're talking
so joseph is not only being fed and
being treated much better than anyone
else at the camp like he even gets
slightly nicer clothes and things like
that
but he's kind of like legitimately happy
to be using his intellect once again
even in this horrible place um you know
where there's really no hope or anything
like that he's like well at least it's
something to look forward to now
although he does obviously despise
colmer he does have to admit to himself
that the man seems to know a great deal
about theological matters and asks
really informed questions and has like
really good insights about some things
so uh the other prisoners though start
to become really resentful that joseph
not only gets a break from this grueling
work schedule um but he's also getting
access to much better and more plentiful
food than you know what they're getting
which is basically just like a stale
crust of bread and like some thin soup
so his former friends or like
acquaintances in the camp that had kind
of like watched each other's backs and
stuff they all kind of like uh turn on
him essentially uh you know calling him
names like he's the pet jew and all this
other kind of stuff and basically like
insinuating that he's allowing colmer to
like have sex with him in exchange for
more food and water and stuff like that
so this very tense situation uh actually
ends up culminating in a pretty horrific
scene which i won't spoil
but suffice it to say that joseph
during the course of this ordeal uh
comes to realize
the depths that he will sink to i guess
in order to save his own skin like how
strong his survival instinct is and what
he'll do to for self-preservation
now subsequently not too long after uh
the camp is liberated by the soviets and
joseph eventually makes his way to new
york city so then the next section of
the book follows joseph there in the
1950s i think it's like the mid to late
1950s i can't quite remember and he's
living a modest life in yonkers he's
teaching theology and things like that
at a local college and he lives alone in
a small apartment but it's like it's a
nice place like it's a decent
neighborhood
one day though when he's in manhattan
for a school meeting
he happens to spot a very familiar face
a guy running an antique shop it's
lieutenant colmer his nemesis from back
in the war
so seeing him brings back all these
horrible members i mean he still has
obviously like ptsd like he has a hard
time running the subway for example
because he keeps reminding him of like
the train journey like going there and
things like that um you know and it
brings back all these kind of horrible
memories so uh seeing him again just he
he's gripped by this horrible like
murderous rage and he's also found out
like in the ensuing years that not only
obviously was his uh wife like you know
raped multiple times and killed at the
camp but also his twin sons were
experimented on by dr mengele so he
finds out that so obviously he's uh very
very angry at this uh whole situation so
he decides that he is going to kill
lieutenant colmer uh and one night he
goes to calmer's place to do exactly
that however before joseph can carry out
his righteous vengeance
culmer shows him something
that sort of changes the entire course
of joseph's life
basically colmer says to him
why do you think i kept you alive and
asked you all of those questions
particularly about angels and demons
then he ends up revealing to joseph that
through his occult studies and through
like something that he found like that
they confiscated from you know the house
of some like uh some people that they
had killed he's like i have
captured a demon
and it will do my bidding provided that
you make the appropriate sacrifices to
it so from that point forward uh various
circumstances conspire to
get possession of the stone that houses
the demon and the book that kind of
tells you how to summon him and how to
send him back and stuff like that uh
joseph gets hold of those
and then we skip back ahead to the
present day which i think is 2019 where
joseph finally discloses
that he's planning to leave the demon in
robert's care like he's passing the
demon on to him since he's like i don't
know anyone else and i don't really want
to leave it you know to some random
person that doesn't know what it is or
doesn't know how to use it because i'm
afraid it'll be like unleashed on the
world and i can't like live with that
responsibility
now robert of course doesn't believe him
at first but then when he actually shows
him like the whole setup and it's like
he actually sees the demon and
everything like that he's like holy [ __ ]
you know i don't really want this or
anything but then he realizes that
through sacrificing animals and people
to the demon the demon will give you
whatever you ask for so at this point he
has to decide whether
what he wants and the main thing that he
wants is you know keeping his mother
from suffering and dying uh is that
going to be worth the price that he is
inevitably going to have to pay so i
gotta say this was a very
gripping and very emotional novel just
not just because of the dog but i mean
it's just yeah this one was really like
a rough one um but i'm actually like
glad that i didn't have any idea what
was what it was about like before i
started reading it because every new
twist and turn was a surprise i
absolutely did not expect the story to
go in like the holocaust direction um
you know so i thought that was really
like surprising i was like oh we're
doing okay all right this is like that
and it ended up being that that part of
the book was even though it was
absolutely like a [ __ ] harrowing
horrifying thing to read
but it kept me locked onto the page like
all the way through like is every fresh
atrocity unfolded everything because
it's horrible horrible like i said it's
realistic it's like written about like
realistic [ __ ] that happened there but
it's just like reading about it like the
way he writes about it is just like
really visceral and it just kind of
makes you
he i don't know he just conveys like uh
what it would have been like to be there
like it's just very you can almost like
smell it and feel it and it's just like
it's it's a horrifying like thing to
read about i have to say too that this
is also a very like heartbreaking story
because
both of the men at the center of it both
joseph and robert
you know the old guy and the young guy
they were clearly very good decent
people
but the circumstances
that they endured sort of ended up
putting them both in a position where
they were willing to do really appalling
things in order to either survive like
save their own ass or to free their
loved ones from pain or death
so it was kind of one of those stories
that definitely made you wonder what you
actually would do if you were put into
that position like would you do the same
thing that these guys have done and
clearly you can like understand why
somebody would be tempted to do the
things that they did in this story
now the book as i mentioned earlier is
quite graphic and gory in places uh and
as i mentioned there is at least one
animal sacrifice but aside from all of
the blood and [ __ ] and bile and fluids
and everything like that that goes on in
this because the demon and everything
like that is pretty gross um you know
it's very uh
moist there's lots of fluids like i said
but really like the true horror of the
story comes not from that it mostly
comes from
this retelling of the sort of you know
the monstrous cruelties that were mostly
inflicted on joseph and his fellow
prisoners and also how their desperation
in those circumstances caused them to
sort of lose their humanity like by
small degrees like in you know small
increments uh robert's story which is
kind of like the frame story i guess um
was obviously like far less tragic and
less epic in scale but it was also
really emotionally affecting in its own
way because it was something i guess
because the horrors that he was
experiencing were lesser it was more
relatable because it's like you know
pretty much everybody can relate to you
know having a loved one die or like get
sick and see them declining or like you
know having a shitty job and having to
put up with that kind of stuff so it
wasn't like you know having to deal with
the holocaust unless you were there you
know the horrors of it it's kind of like
too much i think for most people to wrap
their minds around if they didn't
experience it whereas
i you know robert's story was a lot more
relatable like i said everybody can
relate to the stuff that he was going
through as well even though obviously it
wasn't like a small tiny percentage of
like what joseph went through in the
story and i will say too and i'm not
gonna spoil the ending but the ending of
this was a pretty pitiless twist uh that
i didn't really see coming i have to
admit so uh so there's that so i mean if
you like your horror kind of like real
nasty and savage with
kind of an emotional chord that makes
you feel like you got punched in the gut
then this should absolutely be on your
wavelength from what i could determine
this novel uh particularly isn't as
extreme as some of daniel volpe's other
works but it's still pretty brutal and
gross although this one would probably
appeal more to like a wider audience
maybe than his more splatter punk titles
because it is gross and has some extreme
elements but it's not like all that you
know what i mean um i particularly
recommend it if you like historical
horror particularly stuff because like
half of it is set during world war ii
like so if you like that kind of stuff
then you might dig this as well but i
think that if you're a fan of modern
horror because i'm more of a fan of
modern horror than historical horror
although i like all kinds um then you
should probably dig it as well because i
really liked this a lot even though
i'm not gonna lie it was very difficult
to read it's not like a fun read
necessarily so i don't even know if i'd
call it fun or entertaining but it was
like really really compelling so if that
sounds like something that you would
like then i would definitely recommend
it so that will do it for this tomes of
terror i will see you guys again on the
next one
bye